[Music]
something here seems foul something here
just reeks of blood and suffering
[Music]
of Basel Falls with bloody walls and
countless Scrolls reminding me and see
don't play these games
you've lost your fright I'm up with more
than a line and I'm surviving five
nights no no no just you and me a gun or
three and nothing else between me and
this door you bring the fur
I'll bring the fight hey foxy come get a
bite
cuz I'm surviving five nights you're not
foxy thanks so much for watching night
two of the five nights at Freddy's
musicals believe it or not there's an
entirely different musical all done over
on random encounters channels so check
it out there and if you like that then
you'll like this lid or below guy before
I talk to old I am
[Music]